welcome back to Las Vegas now in today's
legal minute we're learning why one
should hire an attorney after an
accident Eric Palacios from Eric
Palacios and Associates the sponsors of
this segment tells us more
hi I'm Eric Palacios welcome to the
legal minute this week's question is why
should I hire an attorney after an
accident there's three main reasons
number one it's basically a David and
Goliath situation you're up against an
army of insurance adjusters and
attorneys you need a lawyer that knows
the law and is there for you without an
attorney you won't even know when you're
being taken advantage of by the
insurance company number two you need
the best medical treatment with no cost
to you a lawyer can recommend doctors
and therapists that won't charge you up
front not even co-pays this is important
for you to get the best medical care you
need without waiting weeks or even
months and number three representation
in negotiations and Court proceedings
you won't get a lot of compensation on
your own a good lawyer can get you an
average of two or three times the money
so if you suffer an accident call an
attorney right away
give Eric Palacios and Associates a call
or visit their website at Eric
palacioslaw.com we'll be right back